going back to
Russia in the early '90s
I arrived early one morning from a u UK
airport and I went
to
um St
Petersburg and I sometimes I was
teaching some people petburg and
sometimes I would teach where other
students used to come to St Petersburg
seminars and invited me to go to their
um city and
teach and again in the early '90s
to mid
90 I went to a city called chedy pitz
but some of my finest
students are still there
today we arrived we went from St
Petersburg by train overnight
train where you try to sleep but being
not used to
it my students slept very well but I had
a job
myself yes there was a bed very
basic but we
arrived got in a
car and it was just before 7 a.m. in the
morning they took me to this
apartment where there was this young man
by the name of
Sasha at 700 a.m. in the morning I met
this wonderful smiling
face his teeth were not looking so good
and he was drinking a bottle of
beer the television was so loud I
couldn't hear
it he could speak some English but not a
great deal so I needed a
translator we're sitting on the floor
they seem to find that quite normal
because they lived very
basically in the apartment they would
have a a fold up sofa make make into a
bed it was like going back 50 years as
far as the UK was
concerned the furnit is old dark
brown full of and if you you go in most
Russian Houses full of ornaments in the
old glass cases just like my mother
would
have
so I'd arrived in St Petersburg what was
the second capital you know from Moscow
the second largest city a very beautiful
city as that one of the finest I've ever
seen anywhere in the
world
and I couldn't compete with the loudness
of the
television no one was looking at it but
it was very really I mean amazingly loud
you'd never think you could get volume
that
loud they didn't have we'd already got
modern
televisions but they still have had the
one where when I was in apartment on my
own just digressing a moment when I was
in an apartment on my own in St
Petersburg they they walked me around
showed me Basics they said we'll bring
you food we'll bring you water sensey
don't drink the tap water it's brown and
it was brown when you turned it on the
bath was brown the
toilet you pulled to flush it with a
coat with an Old Wire bent coat hanger
and that was quite normal for them they
didn't have a a nice working flushing
toilet and I was in what what they
considered one of their best apartments
in St Petersburg this is going back to
the very early '90s
okay so I'm in ch Vitz and I'm trying to
talk to this young man who
as I say I don't know if he's completely
drunk or whether he's just
happy and we were going to go off to to
train on the Saturday
morning and I said why is nobody looking
at the television and you have it so
loud and why are you drinking beer at
700 a.m. in the
morning he explained to me that life was
of no value in
Russia and the
work they had very little money when the
bosses decided to pay
them so I said well why don't you just
leave and get a better job you cannot
leave your job because if you leave your
job you will never get another
one
because the new person will find phone
the old person and ask why you left the
other person will say something so you
would never get a another job again now
I'm not telling you what I was told you
may deny it and people may say that
can't be true but this is what I was
told
so they could become a taxi driver or
something like that where you would just
work for a company but in a
Factory you couldn't really leave the
the job and if the boss wanted some new
equipment Cherry pitz is a steel mining
town and it has a steel factory that um
would take you train goes very slow when
it goes past it but the steel Works took
about 15 20 minutes to pass on the train
absolutely
massive years later they took me around
to see
it but most of the people in Cher Bitz
at the time worked purely they were
there their accommodation everything was
built to work for the steel
factory and there was this young
[Music]
man I don't know if he was 20 but I'm
guessing round about 20 drinking beer
listen into the
television and I said but you've told me
this about the work but why have the
television so loud and why are you
drinking and he said well it's such an
unhappy
life that we drink to
forget we put the music up because we
want to drown out our
thoughts these films may sound like I'm
having
ago the Russians and because it's a war
going on between them and
Ukraine I'm not what I'm really saying
is that I found these
students who had
nothing in their opinion as young people
to live
for and yet they were the best students
I've ever
Tau so going back to the previous
film where juanin and
shean speaks about all the things that
should be put back into the teaching of
the aikidoka of
today we can't go
back we can only go back if you want to
teach the people in these countries
who are still
living like the Russians in the early
'90s or before that before
perista excuse
me so that's a true story I have many
and I may share them with you in
time
but the iido
of
today will only be
found who will dedicate their whole
being every moment of their spare
time outside of work in these type of
countries because they've got nothing
else to live for and iido will give them
a sense of purpose
value and they will
become superb at
it the problem with this is I watched
the
[Music]
Russians go into the democ
democracies of the way they live the way
they think and they've become
westernized they want all the things the
the iPads the
iPhones a short story of my one of my
dearest and best students still
today 25 years roughly
on when I was invited to St Petersburg
they decided to take me around the
Hermitage what is very famous Winter
Palace
and it has wonderful exhibits it's a
museum of the most wonderful things
you'll ever
see outside there was
a a
truck and I was about to get a marsbar
they were obviously there for
the
tourists I may have told some of these
stories
before forgive me if you've heard
them I asked him oh would you like a mar
bar no thank you
sensey I said but when you with me in
the UK you used to love Mars Bars why
don't you want one now oh that's okay
sensey don't worry I said well look I'm
going to have
one tell me why you won't have one with
me
he looked at me and said Sensei that
would buy a cabbage for my family and if
I have a Mars bar I will feel guilty now
I'm back in
Russia I said to him and I felt guilty
ever since I'll buy you the marbar and
the
Cabbage for your family this is how
arrogant I was
because I didn't realize how that had so
little and how the Western world has so
much the Western world may have a lot of
bad things but it's also got a great
deal of good
things so because it's I'm talking about
I hope I'm talking about life here as
well as
Hyo but we cannot go
back to how things were unless yes were
invited to
countries that are still living in those
50 to 100 years behind the Western
World he went
on from over the years
from telling me about the
Cabbage to visiting me with all his
students and many friends in kefalonia
Greek Greece where we
lived he came on a a dasy
course and and the iPhone had just come
out and he went into a shop in the town
and said can I buy five
iPhones he was enterprising you see he
was going to go back to Russia with them
and sell them for double what he was
buying them
for
more to the
[Music]
point he'd made so much money because of
the
freedom of thinking Western working for
himself and
developing that he had this
ability sadly jumping back to the
politics of this
world Russia is going to go back into
the decline now and I doubt if I'll ever
go back to see them or teach them
again how sad is
that but as we're talking about
originally Juan's
shihan's thoughts about
how we need to become very fit very
flexible very
dedicated very grounded
did we must learn
meditation you know he he's saying every
single thing that I had to do and and
I'm still doing
it I still need
students and this is a part for the
teachers we need students to finish our
journey because the students of today
will not find the journey that we found
but in some countries that haven't yet
had
democracy and haven't had the McDonald's
and all the wonderful bad things that
we've had and the good things I wouldn't
change things
personally I think that what we've got
in the UK America and other European
countries have modernized and seen
improvements in their health their whole
well-being their
finances the the standard of
living why shouldn't the world have this
why shouldn't all the world have
this I will continue this in in the next
film
talking and hoping that you're finding
it of some interest
thank you